Is Luffy half lunarian?
There seem to be a lot of hints pointing us
in that direction.
But first, if you aren't caught up to the
one piece manga, what are you doing here?
Go catch up right now!
Go, go go!
There's spoilers.
But if you are, welcome!
Luffy's fire powers have always been a bit
of an enigma in the one piece community ever
since red hawk was introduced during Luffy's
fight with Hody Jones.
[]
Can Rubber really do this?
But looking at this scene now, knowing that
Luffy actually a mythical Zoan fruit user
with the human human fruit model Nika, this
moment hits very different.
Because we now know that Luffy's powers aren't
only rubber, but actually freely shaping the
world around him as he pleases as we see with
his cartoon powers.
Woah wait a second, where does the fire come
in here though?
I mean Luffy's hair turns into flames, like
Hyogoro, but other than that, the reveal surrounding
LUffy's real devil fruit power has not really
cleared up the fire problem all too much I
think.
The only possible explanation I could come
up with, is that Luffy is able to imitate
other devil fruit abilities, which would of
course be awesome, but I think there might
be a completely different twist here after
all.
WHat's up, I'm Manu, and the user with the
wonderful name of **el_psy_joyboy** of my
subreddit Wild Anime Theories kindly pointed
out to me, Eiichiro Oda the author of One
PIece, might be toying with our expectations
here once again, as he loves to do so often.
Because of course, Luffy's strange ability
to generate actual flame fits wonderfully
with the image of Nika being the sun god and
the sun being a reappearing symbol throughout
the story.
Now sadly, not everyone can have as hot a
hairstyle as luffy.
I know it’s terrible to think about, but
two out of three guys will experience hair
loss by the time they’re 35.
Which is where today’s sponsor comes in.
Keeps offers clinically proven, research-backed
treatments to stop hair loss and improve hair
growth.
My grandpa bolded with like 30 and it’s
stressing me out.
Luckily Keeps is a subscription service that
helps men with just that, keeping their hair.
Their Treatment plans are not only clinically
proven to combat the symptoms of hair loss
and tailored to your personal need, but they’re
also pretty affordable—typically half the
cost of pharmacy prices.
That way you can get quality, expert care
without ever having to visit a doctor’s
office or pharmacy, as they are delivered
straight to your door-step.
And people typically notice results within
6 months of starting treatment.
So if that’s something you’re worried
about, Hair loss stops with Keeps.
To get 50% off your first order go to [keeps.com/Ohara](http://keeps.com/Ohara)
or click the link in the description.
That’s K-E-E-P-S dot com slash Ohara.
The sun is fire, Luffy is the sun god, so
having fire ability makes sense.
Only that as far as his powers have been explained
so far, it doesn't.
Oda has focused so much on the gomu gomu sun
god nike devil fruit story line in the last
few dozen chapters, setting up this reveal,
that it was very easy to overlook the importance
of another big chunk of lore drop: The introduction
of King's lunarian race.
Here's a quick recap: Lunarians are a race
of powerful beings with unique abilities,
that used to live on top of the red line.
Despite their incredible strength, the Lunarians
were somehow driven into almost-extinction,
with king being the last known remnant.
Based on kings appearance, lunarians seem
to be almost angel like beings, they are humans
with dark black wings, way larger than those
of the other known sky people.
Especially through the lens of Oda-sensei's
love for quirky characters, King is probably
the most objectively handsome and perfect
looking Male figure in the story, with long
white hair and dark skin, making it a point
of presenting Lunarians as a elf-like or angel-like
race, that was almost completely eradicated
for their powers.
Now, Interestingly enough the name lunarian
hints at a connection to the moon, which is
not only interesting because of Enel's adventures
on the moon and all the lore that seems to
be hidden up there, but also because the sun
and the moon are the two main occurring symbols
in the story.
On top of that, King has a face tattoo, not
unlike that of Luffy's father dragon, that
seems to depict a flower known as moonwort.
That parallel to dragon by the way would not
only make luffy half sun and half moon, but
also begs the question to wether it was Luffy's
mother or maybe even dragon himself who is
lunarian.
Who knows, maybe god valley was actually the
last refuge of the lunarian race until the
god valley incident happened.
Because, not only were the Lunarians known
as gods themselves, connecting them to Luffy's
sun god title, but they are also naturally
able to produce and manipulate flames with
their body, similar to how the minks are able
to generate electricity or the fish man to
manipulate water.
Which of course brings me back to Luffy and
his strange ability to create fire, long before
awakening his Nika devil fruit.
All this lore drop happened at the same time
as the hints that Luffy's devil fruit might
be special.
Why give us this backstory now, before Luffy's
defeat and reawakening?
Why specifically show us King's background
and not that of Queen or Jack?
We find out that The World Government seemingly
hunts Lunarians around the world to this day,
rewarding anyone with 100,000,000 Berries
for any tip-off about a Lunarian's whereabouts,
at the same time that we learn that they were
trying to get their hands on the Nika devil
fruit for 800 years.
So to me, that suggests, that this is either
related to Luffy himself, or even more specifically
to the Nika fruit.
And who knowns, maybe the infamous D initial
was actually used for descendants of the lunarian
race, kept secret to not reveal its continued
existence to the world government.
Just a thought.
Luffy being part lunarian would not only explain
his fire powers, but also how he was able
to generate enough heat to awaken his devil
fruit powers, as we saw him melting and steaming
at the end of chapter 1043.
What I'm trying to say here, is that being
Lunarian might be a pre-requisite for awakening
the Nika fruit's powers.
Which would not only explain why the government
would try to kill off every single member
of their race, but also why they were not
concerned with luffy having the fruit, as
they didn't know he had lunarian blood.
Step one, be part lunarian.
Part two have the sun god fruit.
Part three be worthy to awaken its powers.
Part four, subscribe to the channel.
Another really interesting detail that supports
this idea is Luffy's eyebrows looking a lot
like Sanji's in chapter 1044.
Sanji who's fire powers have now also been
strongly hinted at being based on Lunarian
dna.
Who we now see using blue flames, like hyogoro's
in the latest cover.
And who I want to add, was the very first
person to notice Luffy's reawakening before
anyone else, despite probably not having better
observation haki than for example Marco.
On top of that, we have Luffy's haki taking
on the form of flames as well.
There were also a ton of other interesting
instances throughout the story, that now that
I look at them again, might be a lot more
important.
For example Luffy not freezing on drum island,
and arc by the way that literally connected
the drums of liberation, the will of D and
the Hito Hito no mi.
Luffy was also literally frozen solid by Aokiji,
but was completely fine.
And luffy generating more heat and steam the
more air he inhales also would work really
well with innate fire powers.
In fact, this would also fit in very nicely
with the idea that devil fruits have a will
of their own.
It's one of the theories I am most proud of,
because it seems to be confirmed more and
more every chapter.
So, if you want to take this to the next level,
don'T ignore this video here.